brandon what do you got for me buddy
well i know your time is valuable so i'm
gonna keep it short here
but
i'm 22 years old
um
i don't really have a whole lot going
for me besides
i mean i'm six foot two and i'm in shape
but i've run into this problem where
i can't really get women
who are
not overweight to even look my way it's
because your smv is not high enough dude
yeah
so if you're only getting gross checked
checks it's because your value is too
low
so or maybe your game sucks i don't know
like how are you with like the game
component of it you're not a virgin
right
no i'm not a virgin yeah
so
last girlfriend i had was in high school
where do you live
nebraska
nebraska
basket that's part of your problem
you're not going to get a lot of
hot-looking chicks living in nebraska
any girl with their heads screwed on
right knows to get the [ __ ] out of there
right yeah
all of these all these small town girls
that are now in like new york miami
chicago la
you know the more cosmo cities
boss girling it up hashtag boss girl you
know go get that corporate gig and climb
the corporate that's where you're left
with all the fatties i bet there's a lot
of single mommies there too right
yeah definitely yeah yeah
so you want to do well in that
environment you're really going to have
to shine dude like you know you got to
be in the top 10 of dudes out there like
you got to be a 9 out of 10 8 out of 10.
and that's to get what like leftovers
that didn't leave nebraska to go to big
big city so i mean like you could get on
the big city and move right
and it shouldn't really
be that hard because it's not like
there's any competition around here
anyway no dude it's it's always gonna be
a challenge men must compete women's
shoes it's always been that way it
doesn't matter if it's nebraska if it's
some [ __ ] amazonian uh tribe in the
middle of the [ __ ] jungle like it
doesn't matter where you are
men have to compete and women will
choose from the competition that's
available to them right so if there's
other guys
that are
more attractive than you you're going to
lose out you're going to be left over
with the
unattractive ones
yeah
so that kind of leads me to my second
question here
should you
practice game
on women that you aren't really
attracted to
like should you play some did you
should you slay a few goblins to get to
the gold you know no i've i i wouldn't
recommend that like listen but i can
proudly claim that i've never gotten
involved with a gross chick okay
so you want to practice on
unattractive women that you're not
turned on by
have at her if that's all you got but
that's like i don't know it's like
working
it's the exact same amount of effort to
deal with a check that you're attracted
to and it's more fun and it's more
rewarding you know what i'm saying like
get to the point of competing is what
i'm getting at right like you want
hotter women you're attracted to hotter
women obviously there's nothing wrong
with that
good everything's firing normally in the
endocrine system
but for you to get those chicks you need
to be better so compete be better or
keep your standards low
and just you know
shoot you know shoot the fish in the
barrel if that's all you want to deal
with the thing about flying with eagles
bran brandon is it's rare not a lot of
people do it most people it's like i'll
hang out on the ground with the turkeys
and i'll just be average and you know
i'm tall so i got that going for me
what kind of car do you drive
toyota camry
[ __ ] boring dude
get a cool car
do you have a motorcycle
no i don't [ __ ] boring dude there's
guys in town that look just like you
but have a motorcycle
right so i mean you know you got to be
captivating with women right like you
know you can't just put on the two can
just rock back and forth and think you
know i'm tall
i got this just
lean into the ones that you want man and
if they're not responding you if they're
not responding to you
then that means you got some work to do
yeah moth made a good point community
fixes this too right you should hop into
one of the communities for crying out
loud man like you know like if you're
struggling with something simple like
how do i get prettier girls
that's an easy problem to fix but we'll
also fix all the other problems around
that that are contributing to the lack
of results that you're getting
i'm kind of new to your channel so
what's the community it'll be pinned
below it's um it's gonna take me too
long to explain but it'll be pinned
below you can go to here i'll i'll put a
banner up i think i have one for it boom
right there
entrepreneursandcars.com forward slash
community go to the website check it out
there's an explainer video
you need other guys to hold you
accountable you need a tribe of men you
need to join a gang
right
yeah because
honestly besides like the couple guys i
left with every once in a while i don't
really
have much of a circle
not really yeah well you're gonna be the
average of the five people that you
spend the most time with and i can tell
by your demeanor by your you know the
way you talk that you're not surrounding
yourself with world-class men
i understand all right you want world
you want world-class babes you got to be
a world-class dude
that one's good to me all right man see
you later hey guys i really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you